ich habe versucht ganz kurz zu machen
die Wirtschaft steht am Scheideweg all
die Themen die wir auch eben schon
besprochen haben Klimaschutz Sozialstaat
Rentensystem sind nur finanzierbar wenn
die Wirtschaft brummt wenn es wieder
Wachstum gibt wir haben seit letzter
Woche die Zahlen gesehen dass
Deutschland eine Rezession im Winter
gefallen ist deswegen muss jetzt wieder
das Gebot gelten erst erwirtschaften
dann ausgeben und das ist das wofür die
FDP in der Ampel Eintritt und wofür wir
sicherlich auch in der Ampel beim
Koalitionspartner an der einen Stelle
noch werden muss
ja viel Spaß beim werben würde ich mal
sagen es ist lang ist ja fast wie eine
oppositionsrede könnte man sagen jawohl
der hat jemand erkannt wo die
Sollbruchstellen der Ampel sind ich
erkenne natürlich an dass das ihr Punkt
ist als FDP in dieser Koalition und das
ist eigentlich einfach haben ist auch
klar aber momentan ist natürlich die
Rezession auch hausgemacht durch die
schlechte Politik im
Wirtschaftsministerium wir haben
momentan ein wirtschaftsbegriff des
Wirtschaftsministerium das vom
wirtschaftlichen Wachstum absieht es
gibt tausend neben Zwecke an dem man
Wohlstand zum Beispiel will wir haben
einen aufwuchsprogramm für eigene Stelle
zur eigenen Stellen 1700 neue Beamten
gibt 17 neue Beamten seit Beginn der
Ampel 30.000 bitte staatsbedienste
mittlerweile zum ersten Mal unterbringen
und es fehlt einfach es fehlt einfach
ein entscheidender Stille die
Wirtschaftskompetenz und da würde ich
sagen es reicht nicht hier gewissermaßen
als innere Regierungs Opposition zu
sagen wir versuchen hier den
klimaschutzminister auch etwas
Wirtschaftskompetenz zuzusprechen es
muss glaube ich auch noch stärker
formuliert werden musste dann auch rote
Linien und wo ist denn auch die wo ist
auch die Schuld unserer Ampel das
europaweit Deutschland wirklich zum
lahmen Mann geworden ist zum Lernen man
Europas was die Wirtschaft angeht und
das ist sehr sehr bedenklich weil wir
verfrühstücken gerade unsere Zukunft die
Frage geben wir mal ein Herrn Bruck den
Europapolitiker weiter wie konnte es
sein dass wir der Name Mann Europas
werden also ich glaube soweit ist es
noch nicht aber ja ist mal 5/4 Jahr sind
es zahlen und dann sind sie wieder
anders allerdings muss man sagen das
gehört schon zu meiner These Dina
herbringen soll das was
Wirtschaftswachstum angeht das
erfolgreichste Land ist Griechenland
Europäischen Union
momentan
und und so gibt's auch andere Beispiele
und in der Tat müssen wir einiges tun
sie meinen wirklich Griechenland ja
Griechenland haben die Schulden
runtergebracht in einer dramatischen
Weise haben ein Wachstum haben eine
entscheidende Verstärkung des Exports
Griechenlands was man vor zehn Jahren
vor fünf Jahren für unmöglich hielt das
ist so völlig überraschend dass die da
vorne mit besten zahlen da stehen und äh
nee also ich habe ja Herr Schulz hat ja
schon Kenia zum Vorbild erklärt dass die
Klimaschutzpolitik angeht jetzt
Griechenland also man sollte
da haben wir einen ein entscheidenden
Punkt wir
auch die Wirtschaft jammern alle wegen
des amerikanischen
antiinflationsgesetzes wir haben eine
ähnliche Akt next generation 750
Milliarden Euro genau für diese Zwecke
wirtschaftlich auf fit zu sein in
Digitalisierung
Versöhnung von Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und
Umwelt zur Politik und so weiter dieses
haben wir leider Gottes nicht
zielgerichtet eingesetzt das sind Fehler
das ist nicht Zielrichtung fokussiert
eingesetzt werden im Gegensatz zu den
Amerikanern was zu machen was wir
Hinblick kriegen müssen ins denken das
ist bei Harbeck nicht reinzukriegen
offensichtlich ist es dass wir nur
Vorbild für die Welt sein können ohne
vernünftige Umwelt Klimaschutzpolitik
betreiben können wenn wir
Umweltschutzpolitik und
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit miteinander
verbinden ja wenn wir nur
Klima auf die niedrigsten werden
Umfragen seit 2018
Ideologie die nicht mit wirtschaftlichen
Notwendigkeiten verbunden ist nicht zu
erreichen wir machen zwei Prozent der
Schäden in der Umwelt in dieser Welt aus
und wenn wir es noch so gut machen nutzt
das dieser Welt nichts aber wir geben
ein schlechtes Beispiel die anderen
Ländern werden mir nur bekommen für mehr
Kampf gegen den Klimawandel wenn wir
unser Projekt wirtschaftlich vernünftig
durchführen wirtschaftlich verlötet das
hat Wettbewerbs wie ich werd und
klimawandelpolitik miteinander
vereinbaren und dieses System Chance
und das schafft diese Bundesregierung
richtig aber das Thema Klimaneutralität
2045 mit dem Klimaschutzgesetz das jetzt
gerade die FDP versucht in ihren äh
Blüten zurückzudrängen in dieser Arbeit
in der Regierung die Klimaschutz gesetzt
haben wir nicht zugeschnitten so das
heißt also das war das war das war das
war die das war die Union die das
Klimaschutzgesetz in der Form auf dem
Weg gebracht hat was jetzt zurückdrehen
müssen das heißt sie haben natürlich
Recht aber wenn du über
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit sprechen über
kranker Mann Europas denn hat Herr Bruch
zumindest hergestellt dass die
Entwicklung im letzten Jahr angefangen
hat sondern wir haben grundsätzlich das
Problem dass im letzten Jahr all die
Risiken die Deutschland angehäuft hat
zusammengekommen sind wir haben keine
billige Energie mehr aufgrund des
Krieges von Russland in der Ukraine und
die Exportmärkte in der
Exportorientierung vor allem nach China
sind ebenfalls nicht mehr so sicher das
heißt das deutsche Exportmodell ist
zusammengebrochen wir müssen jetzt dafür
sorgen dass wir uns neu erfinden
Lindemann hat hier viel deutlichere
Worte gefunden er hat gesagt wir stehen
vor einer Deindustrialisierung Viktor
wie ist die Lage in diesem Land die Lage
ist fatal das hat Herr Meier in seiner
These fähig richtig erkannt da gebe ich
ihm recht nur leider sind sie Teil
dieser Regierung sie sind auch Chef der
Berliner FDP und Sie wissen wie sie mit
Menschen in anderen Parteien umgehen
müssen um Kompromisse zu erzielen dass
ich in ihrer These gerade vermisst habe
ist dass sie jetzt uns hier den
Zuschauern Zusagen das und das und das
biete ich den beiden Koalitionspartner
an um messbare Erfolge zu erzielen was
sind die versprechen aber
brutaler als die FDP in den letzten 9
Monaten sagt wir werden die
Schuldenbremse einhalten wir werden
nicht die Steuern erhöhen wir werden
nicht all das was Gift für
Wirtschaftswachstum ist in dieser
Konstellation mit SPD und Grünen hier
die Linie hält kann man es gar nicht
machen man kann es auch nicht brutaler
beim GG machen da können wir bekommen
kommunikative Fehler reden also das
heizungsgesetz aber die Bremse hier
reingehauen hat die FDP in natürlich
einem zweistufigen Verfahren da kann man
über diskutieren ob wir da Herrn Harburg
auf dem Leim gegangen sind als er
irgendwie im Kabinett sagte nachdem
Christian Linda fragte ob wir nicht
lieber im Kabinett weiter über das
Gesetz diskutieren wollen aber habe
gesagt nein es soll ins Parlament gehen
damit ist da besser gemacht wird
deswegen ist der durchs Kabinett nur
durchgekommen jetzt machen wir die
Bremse im Parlament rein das heißt mehr
an der Stelle in dieser Konstellation
ich sage es noch mal das ist keine
Liebeshochzeit konnte Koalition sind nie
Liebe Hochzeiten und wir reden bei dir
Metall unterschiedliche programmsätze
und wir leben jetzt dass die der dass
die Grünen in der Tat in der Realität
ankommen gewissen Stellen und deswegen
glaube ich werden wir genau dieses bin
dass wir die Wirtschaft stärken müssen
in den nächsten Monaten erfolgreich als
da die messen
wir nicht im letzten halben Jahr werden
wir erst nach vorne sehen das werden wir
sehen anhand
Wirtschaftswachstum
sozialversicherungspflichtige
Beschäftigte Anhalt Rückgang der
Arbeitslosigkeit all die Themen
gegen die FDP sind ist unmöglich ja ich
habe es oft probiert das ist auch in
Ordnung dafür haben wir aber
dem Problem
und da ist natürlich die Frage ist die
FDP vielleicht auch einfach aktuellen
wahnsinnig guter Taktiker auch Kristall
Lindner regiert mit aber ist immer eine
Opposition und sagt immer keine liebes
Heirat dass er sehr Meier gesagt aber
die FDP scheint ja wirklich nicht ist
doublishmen zu sein aber schon ist
dadurch man zu sein ja wasch mir den
Pelz aber mach mich nicht nass also in
einer hat man schon ein wenig das also
die Reden der FDP mit dem zustimmenden
Handel in der Regierungskoalition nicht
immer übereinstimmen dass sie bei vielen
Sachen dann doch Umfeld wie gesagt
Gesellschaftspolitik wollen sie jetzt
gar nicht aufgreifen Migrationspolitik
ist auch ein großes Feld was viele
Menschen das Misstrauen in die Regierung
wachsen lässt und die FDP muss sie
irgendwann entscheiden und wo sind
unsere ich habe vorhin schon gesagt wo
sind unsere Sollbruchstellen und ich
glaube immer wieder zu sagen vier Jahre
lang es werden noch viel viel schlimmer
wenn wir nicht regieren würden und da
würden die Grünen komplett durchdrehen
und die Soße würden ihr Geld verdienen
und wir haben doch wenigstens an dieser
Stelle homöopathisch den Geldbeutel
zusammengehalten und auf wirtschaftliche
Solidität geachtet das wird zu wenig
sein ich glaube irgendwann muss wirklich
mal zum schwache kommen oder muss man
sagen vielleicht das alte Sprichwort
noch mal rausgeholt worden muss lieber
schlecht regieren als niedrigieren
immer mit der Union wer ist auch schlimm
zu regieren immer wieder ne also was
soll das am Ende des Tages
also ich werde für die FDP
nein nein
deswegen ist die Union sicherlich
verloren setzen an vielen Stellen der
FDP ähnlicher aber trotzdem aber sie
hatten regierungs- letzten Jahren
eine ganz kurze Unterbrechung und ich
verspreche ihn lieber Zuschauer gleich
geht's um die Generation Z und nicht um
die FDP bis gleich